Okay, so here's a bag we'd like
to split into roughly two parts.
How do we do it?
Now so far, we've relied on using
patterns from binary arithmetic
to derive algorithms for bag operations.
That begs the natural question,
what's the right analogy for
splitting in binary.
So here's an idea.
What about right bit shifting?
After all, in binary a right bit shift
is like dividing by two which would be
a kind of split.
Let's try it on our now
favorite integer, 23.
Shifting by one effectively
chops off the last bit.
And that will give us 1 0 1 1,
and lo and behold,
1 0 1 1 is 11 in decimal and
that's approximately 23 divided by two.
Okay.
Bur how do we actually apply this idea
to bag splitting?
Okay, let's see how this
works on a simpler example.
So here's a bag whose smallest
pennant is of size 4, in other words,
the 2 slot is full and
1 and 0 slots are empty.
Now, to shift this by 1, or in other
words, slide this somehow into the 1
slot, we're going to need to figure
out how to chop up this pennant.
Because the 1 slot can only
hold a pennant of size 2.
Now let's assume that we also have
a spare bag which is initially empty.
And we'll need this so
that as we're breaking things up or
breaking things apart,
we have some place to put them.
Let's start by splitting
the pennant into halves.
Now we can move one of these
smaller halves into the 1 slot.
This is now a legal operation.
And let's sort the other
half into our spare bag.
Now in the worst case, we might have
to move or touch every pennant.
But remember that each pennant
split only takes constant time.
Therefore, the whole splitting should
be possible in just log n steps.
So again, that's log n splits, constant
time per split, log n overall cost.